you might have been hearing that there  are major changes to copyright law  coming as a result of the new  appropriations bill and that's because  it's true  the new appropriations bill has two main  changes one it makes it a felony to do  certain kinds of streaming  that's not that big of a change because  lots of copyright infringement is  considered a felony just  brings streaming in line with the rest  of those infringements  and the other is creating small claims  court for copyright law  this could go both ways with an uptick  in copyright trolling and people having  to pay as much as thirty thousand  dollars plus  attorneys fees on the other hand you  might have smaller creators getting  remuneration for people using their  copyrighted material i'm gonna have to  think about this it's complicated and  i'll probably do a full video on it but  if you want some holiday cheer check out  the video i did on all the laws broken  in christmas vacation and i'll see  you in court